les véhicules à deux roues et à trois
roues ont la cote
cet été on a une toute nouvelle
clientèle qu'on voyait moins en
concession par le passé un engouement
plus que la normale
la vente de véhicules hors route de
style motocross et vtt a démarré en
force cette saison
vanille moto à québec s'est tout
simplement fait dévaliser on le crut
alors jean yves hinse cette année ont
été sold out
quand même assez rapidement alors vtt
privé que leur route chez adrénaline
sport on remarque le même engouement et
la pandémie il y est certainement pour
quelque chose croît sa directrice
générale
on l'entend je voudrais cette année le à
tous les jours toutes les plans de
voyage les plans de vacances qui ont
changé dans notre client serait dirige
vers des loisirs après les véhicules
hors route c'est au tour des motos à
trois roues l'espagne 2 à battre des
records
je m'amuse souvent comparée entre la
moto et la décapotable
donc c'est très unique par contre avec
les deux roues avant apporte une
sécurité additionnelle versus la moto au
niveau du permis conduire aussi ses
points permis conduire de moto un permis
de conduire qu'il est possible d'obtenir
après une formation de sept heures qui
aident à voir avec la formation d'un an
pour se prévaloir d'un permis de moto à
sacs devant tout de même aux conducteurs
de ces véhicules d'être prudents sans
habitacle ils sont davantage vulnérables
leur pack sida le effectivement un
comportement sécuritaire à avoir faire
attention pour être visible faut porter
les bons vieux équipements c'est
préférable d'établir avec des vêtements
de protection qui est habillé en
camisole et aux baroudeurs plus de vingt
mille véhicules de type spyder rouleront
sur les routes du québec cette année un
chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter
c'est des véhicules aussi que sont très
faciles à conduire il ya un recul en
versus les motos que pour donc le
confort et la facilité de conduite
l'orateur beaucoup clients des clients
contraints de rester au québec mais qui
veulent quand même profiter l'été simard
était à merci radio canada québec